[Applause]
this song goes out to the justices
[Music]
olivia rodrigo is sending a message to
the supreme court after the overturning
of roe v wade during the singer set at
the glastonbury festival in the uk she
surprised the crowd by bringing lily
allen out on stage today is a very very
special day um this is actually my first
glastonbury and i'm sharing the stage
with lily which is the biggest dream
come true ever but i'm also equally as
heartbroken over what happened in
america yesterday
olivia then expressed how she felt about
scotus's ruling on friday in the case of
dobbs vs jackson women's health
organization which overturned its 1973
decision in roe v wade protecting the
right to an abortion i'm devastated
and terrified
and so many women and so many girls are
going to die because of this
and
i wanted to dedicate this next song to
the five members of the supreme court
who have showed us that
at the end of the day they truly don't
give a [ __ ] about freedom
olivia hid her message even harder in
song performing lily's 2009 anthem fu
this song goes out to the justices
[Music]
turns out this was a big moment for lily
she shared the duet on instagram along
with these behind-the-scenes pics from
glastonbury which included a sweet thank
you note from olivia in the caption lily
reflected on the whole thing which was
her return to the stage after getting
sober nearly three years ago quite a
much things are truly messed up but at
least my babies got to see their mama
play and slay glastonbury with their
favorite pop star
[Music]
i didn't know whether i'd be able to get
up on a stage like that sober again if
i'm honest a part of me thought it was
all in the past
lily also ended her post giving hope to
her fans by saying she might not hang up
her mic just yet
[Music]
you